you know it was had me howling laughing
oh yeah
some parts had me that little like dude
the do you remember much of the movie no
not really
do you remember like all like the secret
is or it's like because that yes ladies
and gentlemen I just caught up on the
movie hit when he would like it was like
a fast animation when he would like
chase the kids okay Jimmy you're like
yeah it had me crying
that [ __ ] was scary that had me rolling
I don't know why it was this like it was
so goofy yeah like when the kids in the
basement his brothers like this is gonna
be sick he just like got the blood he's
gonna motorboat your [ __ ] son you better
get out of there motorboats a pair of
titties clean off just so fast he just
slices on with his sharp as teeth no he
doesn't so fast a girl like this know
what happened she will tell me makeup
all over it oh my [ __ ] yeah it's just
his face I'll smear between her chest he
just goes to Cabo with his whole show
yeah you like comes in that little
carnival like a clown like what the this
[ __ ] like opens offices him jerking off
its louis c.k
[Laughter]
[ __ ] what is this oh god that's [ __ ]
up
[Laughter]
yeah his voice he also sounded like Yoda
so just didn't scare me okay what stuff
that stuff's pretty like it's us pretty
particular yeah the other scares the
[ __ ] out of you like weird little things
like that yeah you [ __ ] horrifying
yeah but if you don't find it scary it's
just funny yeah I actually found the
movie more cool and scary yeah I like I
like the idea of like some town where
like all the parents are [ __ ] up like
I don't know it usually when I watch
Horrors I get like really roped in and I
look at it like reality yeah like the
first one I felt like I'd watch them
like believed it was like I don't like a
different setting like it wasn't like LA
or yeah yeah
I go just storytelling so that was cool
you know what was cool actually that a
movie that I just saw that's like that
is uh sorry to bother you I think it's
called oh yeah yeah the movies [ __ ]
funny did you watch it I was little area
oh good weirdest [ __ ] but the end but it
I was like alright this is like kind of
dragging on and surreal comedy for sure
yeah yeah I like the fact that it's in
this like fictional world that's like
sort of like ours yeah like it is like
ours in all respects but it's like also
hilarious with likie Stanfield's voice
being David Cross yeah how was really
fun walking so yeah yeah well look
trying to [ __ ] figure out that guy's
name the whole time the whole movie was
like I said David Spade no no he's been
off David Spade just pissing me off the
whole time I was I was watching baseball
I was trying to think what else in it I
think it was it was the the thing was
that only the kid saw the ghost right
yeah I was like he was like in their
mind yeah right okay so that took me a
minute like understanding that he was
like kind of supernatural yeah um I
think it was scarier like without him
talking yeah like not characterizing him
uh-huh
like I think if he did all the same [ __ ]
but he never spoke it would have freaked
me the [ __ ] yeah humanized him a little
bit yeah the speaking yeah made him like
more real but also like that guy
like with those scenes where he's just
like it just stops yeah like just
staring yeah okay yeah yeah [ __ ] off and
he's like I gotta go take your vote my
oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] oh there yeah when you
mauled that kids arm yep that was sick
yeah I was like oh oh yeah yeah no
shield Jesus is that what this is gonna
be now just relating everything I know
Wow lasers Wow laser didn't get oh nice
kid take your mini I actually genuinely
was thinking that when like they they're
like a crazy sociopath kid was carving
his name into the fat kids stomach I
don't remember that they were like on a
bridge looks like the long barn and like
tomato town or whatever okay like he
like kicks him and he like falls down
this hill and I was just thinking like
quick tree yeah anyway anyway you let
Jack give you the motorboat anyways when
a motorboat - um no no you're creepy
you're weird weird then he does like
that [ __ ] 180 head turn [ __ ] head
goes all the way over his [ __ ] backs
oh that was dope she's like oh yeah oh
my god Rose Sarah look at this sir you
are creeping me out
seriously I'm gonna get my manager he
just starts like breaking as our downs
and like hiding himself in their
air-conditioning vent you oh oh my god
what the [ __ ] is stop it seriously it's
not cool out of my face you are
disgusting
let me snapchat does this is funny oh my
god it's [ __ ] crazy Wow what's her
[ __ ] name oh my god he's in the vent
on my god I'm saying to barstool right
now this is the first Rosie
double tap on the face this guy's
weirding me out oh my god you're crazy
like a leader what is wrong with you I
just want to see her oh my god
yo how weird is this guy pretty much go
into these are going to be yeah what a
weird laugh I'm not fully scared yeah
it's like this guy's disgusting
[Music]
[Music]
these are custom